Oh God we beg of you holiest me but you
give up they're praying to beat the odds
New Jersey's care homes are a dangerous
place to be
twenty-nine people a third of residents
have died in this one over the last
three weeks and many of those still
alive and now sick the home closed ranks
and shut the relatives out nobody told
us they basically I heard it on the news
and no one in the office is answering
questions nobody's giving us any details
nobody's telling us anything so we're
all kind of sitting ducks waiting to see
if someone's gonna tell us that our
family member passed away or Ferg gonna
get a call the next day I really don't
know dear Selena Benitez was a resident
of Elizabeth nursing home this was her
in January 78 years old and smiling and
this was dear Selena last week the last
time the family spoke to her they could
see she was struggling to breathe and
they asked the nursing home to take her
to hospital she died three days later we
believe that she was sick over a week we
had not been notified we had an employee
who let us know my aunt who was over
there crying right now was able to speak
to her through a video call she was not
able to breathe she was she was having
respiratory issues she was exhibiting
all the symptoms and for some reason ER
was she was not taken to the ER this
letter was the first official
confirmation that coronavirus was in the
nursing home it arrived after dear
Selena had died I ate for those
relatives I heard for those relatives
for the simple reason is they get a
letter from the nursing home telling
them what's going on that is not the way
the administrator of this nursing home
should deal with the families who were
dealing with all of this anguish we
wrote to the nursing home
asking them for a statement they didn't
reply so we phoned them please hold a
moment good afternoon I'm a journalist
from Sky News we've been told by
relatives of people in your home that
people been dying and they haven't been
kept informed you had to say about that
there are now daily protests outside the
home and the Attorney General has been
asked to investigate an hour north at
another care home in New Jersey the
police received an anonymous tip-off
telling them that the dead were being
put in a shed they found 17 bodies
crammed into a small morgue on site it
is a desperate situation the elderly
already frail are at the mercy of a
system that is failing them they're
dying in the very homes where their
families thought that they would be safe
Alistair buckles Sky News in New Jersey